[Música]
porque el presidente venezolano nicolás
maduro arriba la habana cuba para
participar en la cumbre del alba-tcp la
jornada hoy tendrá especial importancia
antes del inicio de la cumbre de las
américas donde cuba venezuela y
nicaragua fueron excluidas de manera
unilateral por el gobierno anfitrión el
gobierno de eeuu vamos entonces a
caracas ahí está nuestra corresponsal
daniela zambrano daniela muy buen día
una vez que la casa blanca anunciara
formalmente que no invitaría a nicaragua
venezuela y cuba también de la cumbre de
las américas cual ha sido entonces la
reacción por parte del gobierno del
presidente maduro
qué tal raúl buendía al momento no había
un pronunciamiento formal por decirlo
alguna manera por parte de nicolás
maduro sin embargo coincidió con su
arribo a la habana en horas de la noche
para participar como lo decías en esta
cumbre del alma sin embargo ya se sabía
que venezuela iba a estar excluida y
nicolás maduro se voy a pronunciar y
dicho que le parecía una exclusión
discriminatoria injustificada y que no
importaba como pero la voz de venezuela
iba a estar presente en esa novena
cumbre de las américas que se va a
desarrollar la próxima semana en los
ángeles él bromeaba incluso aunque ya
estaba pidiendo su visa en ese momento
lo dijo que era para asistir a un
festival de salsa en nueva york pero ya
asumía que eeuu no en mitad llama la
atención además que formalmente tampoco
ha sido invitado juan guaidó el
dirigente opositor que ha sido
considerado como presidente de venezuela
encargado presidente interino por varios
países incluyendo eeuu del momento
tampoco ha recibido una invitación
formal a la cumbre de las américas creo
que la mayor reacción es precisamente
ésta del alba a esta cumbre paralela que
se está realizando el día de hoy en la
habana cuba también nicolás maduro había
agradecido a los países que habían
pedido a eeuu que entonces fluyera a
ninguno de los otros miembros y estos
países eran argentina chile bolivia
nicaragua entre otros